um so it gives me great pleasure to
introduce Russell and Parvati Russell is
a professor at UC San Diego and he's an
expert in many areas including
perplexity Theory proof complexity
pseudo randomness and of course
cryptography so many people here prove
hard lemmas but Russell proves hardcore
lamaze some of course talking about the
hardcore lemma which is really the basis
of our understanding of hardness and
complexity and how to manipulate it how
to amplify it but but more generally
much of brussels work really night now
lies at the core of our understanding of
complexity and cryptography perhaps most
notably his famous help paper bills
which puts up the theory of
computational complexity and shows us
how to get all of cryptography from
one-way function of symmetric key
cryptography from one-way functions russ
has done much other work that's of
interest of cryptography including worth
a lot more d randomization randomness
extractions obfuscation Oracle
separation results which field tested
about today and much much more I won't
mention all of it in the interest of
time but I want to mention one thing so
Russell really beautifully comply
conveyed the philosophical implications
of the big questions in complexity by
giving these wonderful whimsical names
to four worlds and you could be living
in algorithmic a pestle and mini crypt
and crypto mania and whenever I get a
chance to teach this or explain this to
someone that hasn't seen it explain what
these words means conceptually it's
really sure way to draw people in and
get them to get them excited about
cryptography complex they understand how
important these questions are so Aras
either new one new one occupation mania
okay so you really heuristic up oh oops
usually forget that one okay Russell has
also been an NSF young investigator a
sloan fellow at fulbright scholar and a
Guggenheim Fellow and is currently
assignments investigator and today
Russell will spill the beans on the
Oracle secrets and you'll tell us about
his work which introduced the Oracle
separation results to cryptography
Thanks this talk is mainly going to be
gossip okay old coffee is historical
it's like old trash becomes you know an
antique this work yeah that's great okay
so I wanted like summarize what
motivated our work it was very primitive
motivations those that's pretty much it
but I'll go it's more detail um so so
let me just start you know historical
actually like make it a fairy tale like
in the spirit of like what Homer was
trying and play back the other day so um
so Russell and Stephen live next door to
each other in berkeley now Stephen was a
very happy graduate student because he
had a nice apartment he had a research
assistantship curing the summer he had
even had like residuals royalties from a
communist board game the computer
version of a communist board game so he
was kind of all set but most important
he had into me
advisor memorable one and I didn't have
any of those things so how did I get
live Steven sometimes took pity on me
and gave me some money and but Steven
would also come home and he would hear
the exciting problems that have only
given him to think about and in so like
every day he would like meet Manuel for
lunch and then he'd come home and we
work we would talk about it in the
afternoon because I was unemployed and
on into the evening because we were
graduate students and whatever you know
we kicked ideas back and forth and then
he'd go to the next day and and have
muffin man Mulligan it and he would like
talk about every everything that we had
discussed so you know what at lunchtime
Manuel would say you know how did that
conjecture that you made yesterday turn
out well Russell found a counterexample
so that's best you know or Russell had
this idea but I probably counter example
this time so so that's how after like a
few weeks of this manuel said who is
this Russell con
and that was that was my opportunity
because Steven told me that Manuel hey
divided me to lunch the next day and
this was very exciting for multiple
reasons so the so this lunch meeting
actually both saved my life from
starvation again change my life in a lot
of ways so this is this is a question I
men will asked during that first lunch I
believe if not shortly afterwards she
said um you know say I've got a random
function it's a great one life function
well you know some there are some things
like big commitment that we don't know
how to do with just a one-way function
and big commitments the key to zero
knowledge and you know so we'd like to
have a one like permutation so could i
use this random function to make a
one-way permutation said but um before
you try any a lot of constructions let
me give you one morning so we can't make
a construction so what we want sorry so
first what do I mean when I say can we
base a one like permutation on what my
function because there are lots of
one-way permutations that we have
conjectured like factoring am I asking
you to break to prove that this is
impossible am I asking you to break
factoring know the reason is why what is
a construction that just uses a one
whiteness of the Oracle in not not any
other problem so let's just assume P
equals NP get rid of every problem that
in real life is hard and then ask if we
give you this random function Oracle can
you use it to make
one we permutation okay so now that was
the model soon p equals NP and then use
the function in some way to define a
random one way permutation but he said
here's here is what it's a little bit
tricky because any instruct what I know
is any construction that's always
guaranteed to be a permutation isn't
going to be one way in this model why
because let's look at and the actual run
of the actual permutation using the the
Oracle f on some input X and say it get
some output Y ok well make some queries
and get some answers make some queries
get some answers well say I take a
hypothetical pre image and look at in
history some s prime that not for that
Oracle but for some other Oracle gives
me the same output why well those two
things are inconsistent so there must be
some kind of witness of inconsistency at
some point in this history in this the
real history the same query has to be
made in the Oracle has to give different
answers otherwise we could take those
two and piece them together and make a
function relative to which pie really
isn't a
attention at all so we can find this
kind of intersection query one where
they both threw the hypothetical pre
image as the same query as the real
history you know we can find a
hypothetical pre image without any
queries to the Oracle because the
hypothetical isn't using the right the
real function f it's using some function
that we make up f prime so using our the
knowledge that P equals NP that's so
this is a kind of NP search problem we
can find a hypothetical on history that
leads to Y and then we'll just make all
those queries and we learn something
about the real history so then we just
repeat this process make a hypothetical
history that agrees with what we know so
far we don't know where that
intersection query was but every time we
learn a little bit more about the real
history thank you until after we've done
this a number of times report to the
number of steps in the real history we
must have have all the information
that's going to give us that the real
history is the only possible for you
this is kind of clear since this is an
idea it's very simple it's you know is
something you can explain to someone who
was an undergrad a few weeks ago I lunch
but this is an idea you so many many
times and in so many different contexts
circuit complexity proof complexity and
so on whatever you're looking for you
know something that might be true or
might not be true you look for different
possible ways that it could be false or
something else could be true and you
look for the inconsistency
so you know that idea has like so many
different variations and it's going to
come up again okay so um now we could so
Stephen and I always call this the one
trick and it's certainly true that
Manuel invented it but so did a lot of
other people so it appears so I finally
managed mental never wrote it down by
himself I finally managed to convince
him to let it him included in our paper
in 87 but by that point on our medicine
and hema Chandra later hot mess and hem
its vendre had published something with
essentially the same idea in 86 and go
for tarnish I didn't independently
discovered the same idea so while men
will do it in 84 he never wrote it down
and so it's not quite clear whether who
really deserves the credit for original
finding this idea and it's such a basic
thing that maybe other people discovered
it under some guys as well okay so um on
the other hand will soon realize is that
happening you know so if we're
guaranteed to have a unique pre image
that makes the permutation easy to
invert in this model but happening to
have a unique pre image is no help at
all because if you just take a random
function without any condition you know
just take the function itself then you
know it has a unique pre image in about
a constant fraction one any of the range
in a constant fraction of the range has
no pre images and it's really hard to
tell which is which and so um you know
finding finding a pre image when it's
unique is no guarantee so there's some
kind of quantitative at you if with real
really high probability probably one
there's any pre image then you can find
it if there's just some constant chance
that there's a unique cream image then
it's hard to find so is you know where
is the threshold where you switch over
from uniqueness helping you to
uniqueness not being in advantage you
know and so Stephen came up with a
conjecture that said that there is such
a threshold and as a constant so he said
let H be a collection of terms a term is
an end of boolean conditions and you can
think of that as a history as an end of
queries and answers and um that that
just has a small number of each of the
terms of size T but there's no limit on
how many terms there could be okay and
there in some boolean variables no limit
on how many boolean variables they
involved the each one involves the most
t of them and so see that the
probability that exactly one of these
histories exactly one of these terms is
true is high bigger than 1 minus epsilon
for some constant epsilon then you want
to say there's some query some are I
random variable that appears in a large
fraction of the terms and so when we
query that variable we learn a lot about
which term is actually true now you have
to like say he has been very clear on
how you wait terms you actually wait
terms according to the probable
they're the unique unique we satisfy her
okay now so we worked on this conjecture
for a long time that that summer and
into the years and really didn't get
anywhere on it so in fact it remained
open for another 15 years it was finally
solved by con sax and Smith using a
technique by rhymer and if you actually
look at the lemma by rhymer I think if
you look at reimers original Emma you
could use it to just directly resolve
the case of one of my permutations
versus one-way functions without even
going through the technically going
through Stephens version okay and what
you get as a consequence is that if it's
all as sort of what what men will want
it if P equals NP then unfortunately
it's a kind of weaker result we'd like
to say if P equals NP that NP intersect
colon P relative to a random Oracle is
in peach of the random Oracle what you
get is that it's in Italy often
heuristic p to the random Oracle okay so
but it's enough to say that if any kind
of one-way permutation construction is
going to be a vulnerable constant
fraction of time for in philly many
lights what's realistically heuristic p
means that you've got an algorithm that
runs in polynomial time in say some on
some fraction of the instances say like
eighty percent of the instances it gives
you the correct answer in the rest of
the time no guarantees
okay and that's how is that so
infinitely often means that for infinite
then a security parameter in the main
values of security perimeter and it's
just annoying yeah why is there that if
we often I can't get rid of it ition be
there okay so um anyway I was actually a
logic student and so like the you know
below I tried to like look at complexity
issues there were all these rough
relativize results I said you couldn't
use a certain class of techniques to
resolve relativized you know certain
basic questions in complexity and so of
course do a logging student these look
like independence results using some
kind of models and so I wanted to like
actually like think about whether there
was a way of making that precise and to
some extent that I did later but this
that's kind of my digression so I wanted
to think about what made a result
relative izing and whether we knew any
results that weren't relevant relative
Isaac in particular did we you know
people said that you know to result
relative izing results men to resolve P
versus NP or MP versus colon P we would
need new techniques and I want to know
is it really crew that we don't have any
techniques that don't relativize you
know or they really knew or maybe
there's something out there that that
that doesn't realize in the one the
other one that that immediately came to
mind because it was a big rage in
the Berkeley theory group was I'm zero
knowledge just just before I started
graduate school Goldwasser McCauley and
yes I gold right McCauley and Link erson
sorry had shown that everything in NP
had a zero knowledge proof in their
original proof involved hiding a three
coloring committing to a three coloring
and then revealing a small part of it
metal had a much better proof because it
didn't require you like to go for n
rounds before you had any any security
he is Hamiltonian tour so I'm exhibited
that here so if you have like a
Hamiltonian tour somewhere in a graph
you permute the whole graph and then you
put down edges and then you either
reveal just yet is that correspond to
the Hamiltonian tour or you reveal the
whole graph and why it's the same as the
original and either one doesn't give you
any knowledge in there are only two
cases so it was a significantly better
on protocol and so men will actually ask
me you know can you do this for other NP
complete problems or are these proud
proms special and so we like worked out
things zero knowledge protocols for
subset sum and three sad and things like
that but all of them use very specifics
of what problems you know what the NP
complete problems were and so it didn't
seem like this was it had any relative
izing analog at least that I could see
so I wanted to know whether whether this
really was a non-relative izing
technique and after thinking about it
for a little bit could see that
um this result doesn't relativize it's
something that I think I never published
or at least never published in any form
that's easily accessible so let me just
tell you about it okay so um it gets
it's really just a very simple idea you
get in and it's not tricky to make it
make it first ice okay so we're just
going to use a random function f and and
what I said before every every yell a
random function f has about 1 in 8
things with a unique preimage and one
any fraction of things with no pre
images and those are the same number so
we're going to use the fact that those
two sets are kind of isomorphic to show
that you can't have a zero knowledge
proof that something's in the range of
the function being in the range of the
function certainly an empty relative to
that function but we're going to show is
that it's not in zero knowledge IP even
with an Oracle for that function so um
so okay and this is exactly just
repeating what I just say so I should
have gone forward okay so say we had a
protocol where a bear approver convinced
the verifier that why was in the pre
image of the the function okay during
the course of that protocol and I'm not
making any bound on the number
oracle resources just that the verifier
makes a series of queries to the to the
function thank you okay let's just
record the queries it makes and then you
know with high probability because here
why really is in the range of the
function the verifier should accept but
if the verifier never queried XSL then
the little use the same protocol on a
function where we just replace the
preimage you'll replace y with some
white pride that has currently has no
pre image and make why have no pre image
okay well then those that that's still a
random Oracle same distribution and um
and moreover the verifier never sees any
difference so so that means that any
protocol that convinces the verifier
soundly under both articles has to have
the verifier has to query X but the
verifier can't compute X by it by
themselves that's the yep is really a
one-way function and so on that means
the verifier is actually learning
something that can't be simulated so
this protocol kit any sound protocol
can't be zero knowledge okay so so
there's just no zero knowledge protocol
for this MP to the app problem so here
we had a technique that we actually knew
in 1984 that didn't relativize and so I
started thinking about why the inner
altima but that's a okay but here again
like looking you know I guess the
essential ingredient is to look at what
the what the queries to the Oracle tell
you about about about the problem was 84
GW was a PC
so
okay so maybe it was 85 I don't know but
when things get published and when
they're known can be slightly different
things yeah so generally shows that ever
growing in p is it zero much portable if
you have a cleveland scheme yes so so
but he remember that i was dealing with
a random function this is why i wanted
it to be a random function so random
function is provably one way hope he
said why i need a commitment scheme
rather than justice but although it
wasn't known that they were commitments
keen space on an arbitrary one-way
function it's easy to come up with
commitment schemes based on a random
function because it is it's close enough
to being one to one so that's a good
point but but it actually it actually
worked out okay so so next next thing we
worked on and relativized cryptography
was secret agreement this is actually
something again manuel ask even think so
secret agreement i think everyone agrees
that a secret agreement is somewhat
paradoxical because you have a you know
I guess traditionally so what what is
like public key encryption or secret
agreement its secrecy without privacy
secrecy in a public forum no there's
been no private communication but
somehow you've managed to construct the
secret and so um so seem to like and I
think you know this is why the the you
know there's always been a popular
appeal to to private key encryption pub
public key encryption I mean more than
private key encryption is that it seems
time
obstacle counter to most people's
beliefs of what's possible okay so
conclusion is that this time secret
agreement public key cryptography seems
a bit magical where steven is an expert
on magic so we wanted to know what the
source of the magic of public key
cryptography was was it just that we
needed really hard problems actually
some people so I think there was a whole
like sub area of complexity that was
looking at this class you Peter psycho
you pee because it had something to do
with public key cryptography because
public key cryptography was all one way
permutations so so we say well well does
it have something to do with
permutations versus functions of
probably were looking at before or is it
that there's some kind of like really
you need some really kind of structure
that only come from number theory to
establish public key cryptography so
where is it coming from heart problems
making solutions uniquely defined or is
it coming from some kind of strange
coincidental structure that you you know
I'll have to look at particular problems
to find thank you I think it's this kind
of issue is kind of is kind of Oh has
played a general role in thinking about
security and cryptography is on the one
there's a tension between any kind of
mathematical structure to a encryption
function is both a strength and a
potential weakness it's a strength in
that it allows you to do things you
couldn't normally do okay it's a
weakness in that it presents
opportunities for attacks the more
structure the isn't
more mathematical structure there isn't
an encryption skill system more
interesting it is to attack so okay so
what we wanted to ask was can we base
secret key agreement just on strong one
my permutations and you know we were
already kind of familiar with the model
we should use it was the same as well we
were how we were modeling the question
of one of my permutations versus one-way
functions so we assume that P equals NP
and say that we've got the dust to get
rid of any kind of known secret key
agreement protocol and we give all
parties the same random in this case of
permutation Oracle app and the reason we
give it a permutation is we wanted to
distinguish between the magic of
arranging permutations in the magic of
having public key encryption first step
let's just say the permutation didn't
matter so why did we talk I said you
know I'm saying public key encryption
and secret p agreement as if they're
kind of synonymous why did we talk about
secret key agreement rather than
directly about public key cryptography
one reason is that things like public
key cryptography is the means to an end
public key cryptography is one way of
getting a secret but the end is getting
secret information from one person to
another so even if there were some kind
of loophole that allowed loud you to
achieve that end without going through
the means of public key cryptography we
wanted to roll that out um and the other
thing is that public key cryptography
either had no depth no universal
definition or to strip the definition
some people to find it quite clearly but
it was exactly in a way that the defined
to be almost exactly are
say nothing else for RSA like and
nothing else so like those some of the
lattice face public key encryption
wouldn't have met the standard
definition at the time so we wanted to
avoid committing ourselves to a
particular definition and just look at
any way of accomplishing a task okay so
the other thing is well if you just try
to show that there's no black box
construction of a a secret key agreement
skene from a one-way function you can
come up with any article in which secret
key agreement is not possible relative
to that Oracle and yet there is a
one-way function but we really were
really kind of committed to this
particular Oracle construction and the
reason I guess was that first articles
are so flexible that there are so many
Oracle constructions in in complexity
that a lot of people thought they were
cheating you know you were using the
power of defining historical in strange
ways to make the theorem whatever
theorem you were trying to show true and
the Oracle complexity relative to the
Oracle didn't have much to do
intuitively with with real complexity so
we wanted to show that here was actually
like a problem a kind of world where
people would have thought this is a good
world for cryptography and public key
cryptography is not possible in that
world okay a world where there's an
immensely hard problem
to everybody okay so and so that would
be something like here's a world with
all the hardness that you could want but
no structure to that hardness and so try
to answer the question of which where
does the magic come from is it hardness
or structure in favor of structure ok so
there's another hypothetical motivation
that we should have been motivated by
but because we were kind of ignorant
graduate students we work and that's
historically the first secret agreement
protocol predating diffie-hellman was
the Merkel key agreement protocol and
the Merkel key agreement protocol uses
exactly this model of queries to a
random function so in the in the Merkel
scheme you have just n squared possible
keys in Alice pics about n of them and
sends a very hard function random
function of those end keys to bob or to
the world doesn't have to be devolved in
particular when Bob wants to agree on a
key with outlets he just keeps on
computing keys until he finds one that
matches one of Alice's keys and sense of
that says ok Alice was picky number 17
on your list ok I know what that is ok
so um and the secret is that key and he
showed that essentially there was a
quadratic gap between the attacker and
the participants in this model because
of the birthday paradox Bob finds an
intersection key query in about ten
steps and so both Alice and Bob work for
order n time whereas an attacker
to to basically do exhaustive search so
so that was that's a potential
motivation and if we had been you know
up on our history we would have been
motivated by that but here's our actual
motivation I said hunger is a big thing
this is important i wasn't able to have
a printing color it's much more tempting
in color this is the pomegranate chicken
at law better training which is on
college and the omelet area it is very
good and is it sort of on the pricey end
of a portable to a grad student you know
twelve dollars or something like that
you know keep it now keep her at the
time and I have to tell you you know
this is this is the this is the product
placement portion of the talk i went
there like I wonder last last a week ago
Saturday and I ordered the pomegranate
chicken and it's still just as good the
restaurants still there it's exactly the
same the chicken is exactly the same and
it's just as good as I remember so pure
a dome would go to la méditerranée and
get pomegranate chicken I've never got
anything else there so I together
say whether it's good okay so so well
because even and I had the this kind of
this kind of tradition whenever we prove
something good we would go to la
méditerranée and have chicken
pomegranate to celebrate and the most
important thing is while we were eating
the chicken we never really thought
about whether the proof had any holes in
it you know it's after after we're done
with the chicken week we go back and
think about whether the proof was
actually right so so by on this problem
we got to have chicken who a numeral
whole number of times you know and we
were sure that we could solve this
problem because it was almost the same
as the problem we failed to solve before
so hey me because you know just like
before this question of finding the
finding the secret really was a question
about finding intersection parties
between hypothetical histories and real
histories the reason is well if there
weren't any intersection queries that
Bob and Alice never asked the same
question during a protocol then really
we could just give them different
Oracle's and they wouldn't know the
difference right and if we're giving
them different Oracle's hey they don't
need no Oracle they can just simulate
random answers and then you've just got
a traditional public key cryptography
public you know secret create agreement
protocol without any articles and since
P equals NP we can just break up okay so
um so we knew one thing we knew because
now by now it's them
Katie six or so is a we had taken
sisters complexity class and we knew
that there was a result of jeremy's and
clear that uniform generation is
equivalent to approximately County and
there was this result of stockmeyer that
said approximate counties in polynomial
hierarchy so we can do uniform
generation in a world where people's MP
and so we just did that all of them we
knew we could so we did it was clearly
what we wanted to do so what we want to
do is somehow uniformly generate
potential Alice's potential history and
compare that to the real Bob and try to
find the place where those potential
Alice's intersect with the real Bob now
we know the real Alice intersects with
the real Bob and that's what we just
said but so we need these potential
offices in some sense to be close to the
real analysis and that's where the
problem starts because it's not really
crew at least not at the beginning you
start simulating potential Alice's and
look at the query intersection queries
seem like you see we did Merkel the
Merkel protocol not with the original
function f but without composed with
itself so then you see well eventually
they're going to make an intersection
query but then they're going to make
another intersection party when they
find an intern when I was involved
intersect one point they're going to
learn what F at that point is and then
they're going to intersect it up at that
point and that's the in effect is done
until we make this intersection query
that we know what the secret is ok so um
so when we start doing potential Alice's
we're going to just make up what this
function is so we're going to make this
set of query sure incite this would be
but this set of course is just going to
be way off it's going to be out in
nowhere have nothing to do with the real
Alice so at least the beginning we can't
really say that these these potential
Alice's look at it all like the real
elves so so we trying to come up with
another approach which is saying okay
well let's try to like you know they
have to build up those those
intersection queries that we missed the
first time so let's try to just get the
first intersection worried and then once
we've got the first intersection query
get the second intersection query and so
on build up build up a list of
intersection queries and finally kind of
converge on all the intersection queries
well say we succeeded we found out the
intersection parties so now is you know
except for what we know Alice and Bob
are independent right they're basically
using separate Oracle's and we can this
do that do that kind of argument that we
have before since they're independent
when we simulate an Alice it's really
the same distribution as the real
alice's from so that was a that was the
second proof we came up with one of the
early proofs we came up with tom is it
actually true because even if you happen
to avoid all the intersection parties it
doesn't follow that that is the same as
if they never made an intersection query
because there were all the intersecting
queries that they might have made but
then and that actually tells you
something so conditioning on them not
having made intersection queries
actually doesn't work it doesn't cause
them to be independent and the
dependencies get pretty hard so and you
know maybe we drop the project
or we thought but at this point Stephen
went on a trip and he learned that there
was this other team that was working on
the same problem using the same model
they were actually motivated by either
Merkel Merkel puzzles whether it was
actually optimal which is the first time
we actually heard of Merkel I'm afraid
so so we started like saying let's go
through the you know but now we're under
time pressure now we have to like
compute all those conditional
probabilities that we were trying to
avoid before and try to get the the
proof to work crew and at some point we
had succeeded okay and we wrote up an
abstract you know put summary of our
results and we wanted to announce it to
the world to make sure that you know we
got at least credit for being
independent of this other group which
had more famous people involved or at
least one famous person involved and so
we want to be sure that we didn't get
scooped so we we wrote up something and
Stephen volunteered to give a talk on
this at IBM and in all the way and so
the night before the talk we had this
argument about exactly how to compute
these conditional probabilities and
after I went home so Steven had like one
formula and I had one for me and after
he flew at home I was going to prove to
Stephen that I was right so I concocted
an example where his formula was totally
wrong I felt good until I tried my
formula
it was almost right but closer than his
butt so I I stayed up all night trying
to think at least I had this example
we're both over formulas were failed but
I didn't know why because the proof
still valid so I stayed up all night
until I found the bug in our proof and
that I called Stephen to tell him I
found the bug in the proof and he had
gone tammana he gave the top no one
noticed no one even asked about the type
of guy you prove okay so um anyway but
he came home and then I told him the bug
and then we went into a panic mode okay
so um so after like we didn't want to
tell anyone for you know until we were
sure that this bug was was persisted but
after a couple of days we finally broke
down and we're not going to fix this
easily and so we called magma and we
said manuel oh it's horrible there's a
bug in our proof and we've already
announced the result and Panama said
there's a bug in your proof yeah how
exciting
anyway I'm not sure whether that's
inspirational or bad knee it was
probably both so um anyway then I
remember we had like an emergency
meeting with manuela new mesh and we
went all went out and umesh gave us his
theory about how to handle such
situations which involves precisely
measuring the amount of sake you drink
so but um so but anyway a few weeks went
by and we still haven't fixed this fun
and then Stephen tells me out of the
blue here's this kind of lemma I think
it's going to help us I think it's the
key well and I said okay well Steve it
so how does it help us he said I don't
know and simple okay but can you explain
why the lime is true said no I can so so
I'm for another few weeks on the problem
and in the end i discovered the stevens
lana was indeed the key lemma and by
that point I knew both why work like it
was true and and and why I proved the
theorem I don't remember but I knew at
the time but so this paper 3 Blake was
with one of the most psychological
scarring for me uh-huh so I was kind of
afraid of giving this talk but so
because I have to like go back and look
at the paper but after I look at the
paper it's actual
not so bad I was gonna I beginning a few
weeks ago when I said was giving this
talk I said the most important thing to
learn in this talk is to never read this
paper but they actually look at it and
it I didn't remember it but it's not so
bad and it says here is the most
important lemma it just says that in the
paper okay and here it is okay and it's
not it's not it makes sense okay
probably means i'm making some mistaken
okay so um so the counterintuitive step
was instead of continuing on what Eve
knows about Alice let's condition on
what the real Bob knows about Alice well
how can we do that because we have you
know if we knew what the real bob was
thinking we know what the secret was but
here is the idea the real in the real
pub so we have a set of hypothetical
Alice's that are consistent with
everything the eavesdropper notes in
real bob has some history and knows some
information now if we knew what real Bob
knew we'd be able to divide the
hypothetical Alice's into the two groups
the ones that don't intersect with Bob
Bob's queries in anything that we don't
know and the ones that do intersect okay
now what we showed it's not so hard is
that any hypothetical Alice that doesn't
intersect with the real Bob from Bob's
point of view is equally likely as any
other and then that sort of makes sense
because you know you change one world
over here to another world over here
doesn't change anything the bob is
actually seen they're all consistent
with the conversation and the queries
they make are disjoint except for
ones that we that were fixing so the
real Alice condition on the real house
not having had a previous intersection
lip off and remember we're sort of
working our way up with the finding all
the intersections in the first I and
then continue on its for the first I
plus 1 so the real Alice conditional on
that event happening happening is
somewhere in this subset of hypothetical
Alice's that don't intersect and it's
uniform in that subset what we can do is
we can't like uniformly sampled from
just this subset of real that are close
to the real Alice's we can uniformly
sample from the whole set and that has a
kind of a win-win analysis so if the
part that does a dinner set is big then
or sampling is most of it then we're
sampling basically like the real Alice
and if it is big then whatever we're
sampling we were learning something new
about Bob Weir intersecting the pub with
some non Nigel probability and so either
way we get some information that's
relevant ok so we call about this other
group so we finally had the proof wrote
it up we called up this other group and
they say oh yes we have the proof too I
said great let's write a joint paper and
submit it to the next conference said
okay but I'm on the program committee
for the next conference so will delay
about a year ok so like nine months had
passed and I said well ok now it's time
to actually write the paper so I called
up this group and they said oh yes we we
know less it was so what we've written
up some part of the paper but you were
saying that you actually prove not just
said there was a
niall time method to break the incracy
critique payment but you actually prove
that the Merkel scheme was optimal in
this person said to me yes well it's
kind of simple you know you're like the
guy who props a coin and looks under the
light to find the coin even though he
dropped the coin in the dark area we
went into the dark and found the point
it's a simple cake grade that reminds me
so much so I like um y value went into
the dark can you tell us what you found
there you know and give us the proof so
he finally like describe what they were
doing and it turned out to be not just
the it was the the problem where I
stayed up all night it was like one of
the bugs we found three or four months
before that so my conclusion is the
reason why you look under the light is
that bad things happen in the dark so
anyway but so so we've actually just
publish it by ourselves but it did cause
like a nine month delay okay fortune in
the end it took another nearly 20 I
guess actually 20 years so all these
issues don't come up sit there one
message one drowned keep to message key
cream and protocols right um did you
shoot dependents are actually i'm not so
clearly convinced they don't just wait
so it's actually like the induction was
based on the number of queries that were
made not the number but number if you
look at the Merkel scheme with like to
put function of function there is
actually still gets a one-round scheme
okay so 20 years later boas barack and
muhammad mahmud ii jittery actually went
into the dark in and found the point
that was dropped they're proving that
Marco puzzles are optimal one other rule
later result that I want mentioned
because I'm not sure a lot of people
know about it is a Stephen actually then
went on to show an Oracle relative to
which there are K round secret
agreements but not k minus 1 round for
an arbitrary k so though it says that
that separates the Tasca secret key
agreement from any particular kind of
format for keeping secret agreement I
think that's a really interesting result
not sure it got a lot of publicity okay
and then it took about another 10 years
before anyone did some something similar
beat again but after that so first with
some work of dan Simon and some Kim
Simons and totality and later work of a
group of people the the notion of black
box separations between different kinds
of cryptographic tasks really took a
took off and now i think you know we're
almost in the the situation of like
complexity in the 80s where we we've
separated everything so um so what's
left to do well i think the most
important thing not to do is you know
we've shown these non simulations not on
black box constructions in the most
important thing to do is start coming up
with start doing this in
some of the reductions anyway because we
know um so on one hand we know that we
can't do this in a black box way but we
also know and this is something we knew
back in 85 or 86 a few techniques in
cryptography like NP is in zero
knowledge IP that are really basic and
don't realize so there's actually no
these black box separations shouldn't
really be an excuse for not showing a
clip on sort of these primitives it just
should give us guidance in how we how we
find the constructions
that's it